you've seen the universal logo before
every time I'm in a theater and I'm
waiting for the movie to start and I see
those big giant metal letters appearing
over the earth I can't help but feel
that there's a disaster movie happening
as I'm waiting to watch another movie
what if the universal logo is real I
don't know and I want to figure out the
answer with you that's right I'm
bringing you along for the journey to
answer the question of what does it look
like what would happen is this even
possible are you hungry I'm hungry did
you want to eat lunch no I already eat
lunch never mind I'm good
um
that was my dessert here is the logo
we're dealing with in science normally
when you try to answer a question like
this you come up with a hypothesis first
what do you think is going to happen in
this situation it's not that I think
anything is going to happen it's that I
want something to happen what I want is
for all of these characters to have so
much mass that it just rips up the
ground on Earth and stuff goes flying up
into the air
it's tasty what if the universal logo
was real I'm a little nervous because
there's already a little bit of
information about this oh whoa dude look
at this they've already got it up in the
sky okay we're onto something here right
off the bat so they already did it then
they didn't do it cancel the video
cancel don't cancel wait don't turn it
off but no don't cancel the video we
just started you see this right here I
don't even know if this is right I mean
that's why we're doing this video oh hey
look metabol Studio he's made a bunch of
stuff showing context of scale
now that's some context of scale right
there oh okay
that's just the you that's just the U is
that the United States
oh wow that's cool that really kind of
puts it into perspective how big this is
do you think these letters are big
enough to have their own influence on
gravity dude I hope so I don't know yet
but that's what I'm gonna try to figure
out what are they gonna be made out of
another good question I haven't gotten
to that one yet it looks like they're
made out of metal I assume they're made
out of metal this is a great starting
point but I want to figure out what
would happen and since Universal won't
email me their project file I have to
recreate the logo from scratch so that I
can get an accurately scaled 3D model of
each of these letters so I can figure
out the volume of each of them so then I
can figure out how much each of those
letters weigh so then I can actually
figure out what the gravity of them
would be and if that would actually
affect the Earth basically I know the
exact size of the Earth it's 12 742
kilometers wide by scaling up this
sphere to the exact size of Earth I can
then determine how big the actual
characters are in relation to that by
simply measuring its size also haircut
transition
okay so I built out the universal logo
to scale I got it as close as I could I
even got the bevels as close as I could
this was the key ingredient I'd been
missing up until this point now we can
proceed so before we even start talking
about gravity mass volume and all that
stuff we can actually straight up just
put a camera on the surface of Earth
here we live here in La so I'm just
going to put the camera roughly here in
La I think that's about right here so
okay since the universal logo is
basically going around the equator
that's due south from here right now so
I'm going to point the camera South
this is what it would look like
[Applause]
okay so if that's what I mean obviously
the ground is all like kind of wonky
looking but roughly that should be what
it looks like here you know what why are
we looking at this janky render let's go
up to the roof and actually take a look
I swear every time I come into this room
something goofy is happening
oh man it's so bright there it is look
at that
[Music]
man this is crazy it stretches across
the entire Horizon here just a big Arc
like the world's biggest double rainbow
all the way so most people think that
the universal logo would be like
directly above their heads and if you
live in Brazil that might be the case
but we are pretty far north here in Los
Angeles so we're looking down on the top
of the letters there the further north
you go the more that this is going to
disappear behind the Horizon in fact if
you live in Alaska you wouldn't be able
to see the universal logo at all sorry
Alaska you don't get no movies alright
so now that we know what it looks like
we can actually use all this to figure
out the physics of all of this it's time
to do some math and actually figure out
if this really would be a disaster movie
oh God
physics to figure out how this will
affect the earth I first need to figure
out how much each of these letters weigh
how much mass they have but to figure
that out I first need to figure out how
much volume they have how much space
they take up fortunately I have a
plug-in in c4d called long Suite I can
just press a button and it tells me the
volume which is great I have the volume
now but that's only half the battle to
figuring out their Mass we need to know
what they're made out of what materials
are these I mean it looks like they're
made out of metal I think it's safe to
assume that they're metal but there's
lots of different kinds of metals what
kind of metal would the universal logo
be also are they hollow hollow or solid
I was assuming they're solid they could
be just like freaking blankets
set is the universal logo Hollow or
solid I think it's Hollow Griffin Hollow
or solid oh dude that thing's totally
solid Hollow or solid I'd go with solid
probably Apollo or solid solo
definitely solid solid is this the real
microphone yes
hollow hollow solid oh my God freaking
solid half son I think it's safe to say
that we can assume that these are just
solid metal
thank God because that makes my job
easier what are they made out of oh my
god do we have to do another poll the
whole thing could be platinum with a
little bit of gold lining or it could
all be silver which is a lot lighter
actually okay I just realized the
density of platinum and gold are almost
the same
Platinum Platinum yeah I now have the
density of platinum and I have all the
volumes I can multiply those two numbers
together to get the mass that will allow
me to figure out how much gravity these
letters have Universal letters if you
were to melt them all down into one like
Platinum Moon it would weigh one
trillion trillion kilograms that's
insane
this is shaping up
Earth is like 5.97 trillion trillion
kilograms this is 1.2 trillion trillion
kilograms Earth weighs five times more
than the universal logo so the next step
is to
additional forces the equation is
actually
acceleration due to gravity ever heard
of g-forces you basically just take your
mass and you divide it by the radius of
it squared so the giant Platinum Moon
above me if I was to stand on its
surface I would actually feel heavier I
would weigh 50 more on the Platinum Moon
than I do here that is insane because
this moon is a lot smaller in size than
the earth but because it's so much more
dense we're talking like five six times
more dense and the radius is so much
smaller that I feel that gravitational
pull so much more greatly
worn greatly
so surely with it above my head it would
lift me up off the ground right that's
what I want I want to be lifted up off
the ground I want this to be a disaster
movie but it's not all in one big
freaking sphere above my head it's
distributed across the sky which means
I'm going to have like gravity affect me
from that way gravity affecting me that
way upwards here and I don't exactly
know how to calculate the gravity for a
big distributed area
I don't know how to figure it out
I feel like I need to talk to an expert
about this so I have a friend I think he
can help me with this
what are you doing
we're doing Hands-On size I actually
have a phone call with the real
scientist right now so I gotta go
gatekeeping side
if you haven't heard of Scott Manley
then you probably don't like rockets if
you do like rockets then you like Scott
Manley that's all that needs to be said
dude first off thank you so much for
chatting with me so I'm trying to figure
out what would happen once it has
arrived now that it's here like will it
lift people up off the ground you know
the Earth you could imagine it's like a
big drop of liquid magma and it takes
time to sort of relax so if they just
fly by and go off into space stuff we'll
be bad but maybe not terminal let's say
we're assuming that they're just stopped
and they're not in orbit they're just
hovering there through whatever Force if
the letter e is directly above my head
with the other characters which are like
slightly to the side of it and like past
the Horizon would they also be affecting
the gravitation they're pulling you in
different directions so yeah how would I
calculate that you just under a point
Mass one for each ladder at the correct
position okay and then you've got one
big Point Mass at the center of the
earth and you can just add these up as
Force vectors and it's super easy to do
sure yeah just add the ball up okay so
like there's a lot of upwards total
Vector going up but then you also have
vectors to the left and the right
pulling which would cancel out
presumably but if you're saying on the
side of the earth here you will have
more in One Direction than the other
right so you're so it's going to be like
if you're on the sides of the earth you
know 90 degrees away from the center
you're gonna feel like it's going
downhill right everything will be
flowing downhill water is all gonna rush
to the equator because that's going to
move faster than the rock a little okay
you don't have any ocean at the North
Pole anymore because all the waters run
so so the further north you are the less
air you have to breathe because it gets
soaked towards the Equator so people are
like up in London or whatever they are
air is rushing down towards the Equator
so be very windy and then they'd
suffocate yeah pretty much poorly and
even if these are massless even if
they're just like projections they're
casting Shadows that are going to be
messing with the ecosystem right you
know either other curved areas that
would make like a parabola Focus the
light into like a beam yeah in theory
like the S like the inside of the S
could probably like focus it at the
right spot on Earth
that was curved and it was like melting
yeah yes
that's like a freaking death rate from
space hey look a movie's starting and
then you just fried
the Earth is toast yeah
yep
the Earth is not going to be left Scott
blew my mind turns out I do know how to
figure this out I just didn't realize it
it sounded complicated vectorizing the
gravitational forces but once you
actually break them out into the X and Y
coordinates they just add up and so
everything from the left and right
should mostly cancel out and everything
going up will add up I'm just adding UPS
This Is The Moment of Truth add up all
of these gravitational forces from the
universal logo to figure out if it
really can just lift me up if you are
right underneath the e
you would feel 14 percent lighter
that's it yeah
this is science it doesn't matter what I
want for I mean like 14 like sure I
might be able to jump an extra inch or
two higher not quite the disaster film I
was anticipating but Scott and I've been
talking and turns out I have yet to
account for probably the most important
ingredient of all and that is time so I
think it is time to tell you what time
will do let's hit play on The Sim see
what happens
the universal logo suddenly appeared one
day in orbit you wouldn't initially
notice much unless you lived near the
ocean because you would be one of the
first people to perish from this
cataclysm instead of Tides there would
be giant tsunamis wrecking every
Coastline in the world multiple times
per day over three billion people live
near the coast and all of them would be
underwater as the waves reach hundreds
of miles Inland if you are lucky enough
to find The High Ground well now you
have to contend with out of control
tornadoes and hurricanes as the air
rushes towards the equator and the
world's oceans would also migrate
towards the equator forming a new
oceanic belt around the entire planet
leaving the rest of the world dry
because the tidal forces from the
universal logo are a million times
greater than from the Moon the Earth
itself begins to deform the equator
bulges outwards hundreds of miles
causing near constant earthquakes
volcanoes erupt as the magma is squeezed
out of the mantle the universal logo is
already devastating everything you love
but it is just getting started up in
space
beginning to unfold the letters are so
dense that instead of breaking up into a
beautiful ring each letter would
collapse under its own gravity they
would begin crashing into each other as
their Collective gravity brings them
together into a single New Moon you
might be safe in a submarine at the
equator but you won't be safe for long
the collisions between the letters in
space literally Splash molten Platinum
out into space which then falls down to
earth as the hard rain each Platinum
raindrop could have ended the dinosaurs
on their own but the rainfall of so many
all at once truly redefines what hell is
the atmosphere heats up thousands of
degrees and the oceans boil eventually
the entire surface of the Earth melts as
well and nothing could possibly survive
that it is over for us but you might be
surprised at what eventually happens
millions of years later our once
beautiful planet has finally cooled off
and solidified the oceans have even
reformed after centuries of constant
rain but in place of a shiny metal Moon
there would appear to be another Earth
ejecta from the initial bombardment sent
out enough debris into space that much
of it ends up landing on this metal Moon
forming a rocky crust and even tiny
little oceans Both Worlds resemble what
the Earth looked like billions of years
ago and who knows maybe life could one
day evolve again but on both worlds This
Time Imagine looking up into space at
the other world with those living there
looking back at us wondering what life
must be like here I feel like there's a
movie idea here and I think Universal
Pictures should make it oh wait thank
you so much for watching this video I
tried really hard to make this as
accurate as I could but I am definitely
no orbital mechanical scientist at all
but someone else is Scott Manley is
making a video going into much greater
detail about all the math and the
equations involved I recommend checking
it out the video is linked in the
description or just you know click click
whatever's over here you know click it
still haven't clicked it yet you got
five more seconds